I think pretty early actually so when we
saw that the fine pattern of these hands
forms a strictly hexagonal structure so
very very regular almost like a
coordinate system then that was a whole
different from what anyone had expected
that we knew this would be kind of
revolutionary so we worked on really
being sure that there was no mistake in
the data with lots of control
experiments and we sent it to nature and
went right in so that kind of confirmed
our suspicions but it was important yet
it was of course difficult to imagine
that only nine years later it would be a
Nobel Prize that is perhaps beyond but
still we we knew that it was very
important from the beginning yeah and
the exciting part of of these cells is
like ender said that we try to do all is
control to find out Easter especially
specific order does the rat see
something specific that makes this sir
grid pattern and there's none and and
that means that this pattern is
generated by the brain itself and then
it's like going into the brain and
detecting the mystery of the brain by
studying these cells and if we start to
understand even more how they are
generated we understand so much about
town during the brainless working